Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. My lord of Hereford here, whom you call king, is a foul traitor to proud Hereford's king. And if you crown him, let me prophesy, the blood of English shall manure the ground, and future ages groan for this foul act. Peace shall go sleep with Turks and infidels, and in this seat of peace tumultuous wars shall kin with kin and kind with kind confound. Disorder, horror, fear, and mutiny shall here inhabit, and this land be called the field of
感谢您收听《历史的余味》。想要获取每周的额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我这位赫里福德的领主，你们称他为国王，却是赫里福德骄傲的国王的卑鄙叛徒。如果你们为他加冕，让我预言，英国人的鲜血将肥沃这片土地，后世将为这一卑劣行径而呻吟。和平将与土耳其人和异教徒一同沉睡，在这和平的宝座上，动荡的战争将使亲族与亲族、同类与同类相互毁灭。混乱、恐怖、恐惧和兵变将在此栖居，这片土地将被称作战场，
Golgotha and dead men's skulls. Oh, if you raise this house against this house, it will the woefulest division prove that ever fell upon this cursed earth. Prevent it, resist it, let it not be so, lest child, child's children cry against you. Woe. So that is the Bishop of Carlisle, William Shakespeare's Richard II.
那是各各他，是死人的头骨。哦，如果你让这房子对抗这房子，它将证明是降临在这片被诅咒的土地上最悲惨的分裂。阻止它，抵制它，不要让它发生，免得孩子、孩子的孩子向你们哭诉。悲哀。这就是卡莱尔主教，威廉·莎士比亚的《理查二世》。
And that moment, Tom, comes at the fateful moment, doesn't it? The climax of Shakespeare's great play. A play that is not one of the most performed in the Shakespearean canon, but it has some of the finest writing, some of the most beautiful passages. I thought you did wonderful justice to it.
汤姆，那一刻，正是决定性的时刻，不是吗？莎士比亚伟大剧作的高潮。这部剧在莎士比亚的作品集中虽然不是演出次数最多的，但它拥有一些最精妙的文字和最美丽的段落。我觉得你演绎得非常精彩。
Well, that is kind. I especially loved the catch in your throat in the final few lines. Well, that's what a great actor... As you contemplate England turning to civil war. Very, very moving, Dominic. It's not complicated, Tom. It's just acting. I know it is. So that's the moment on the 1st of October, 1399, when Richard II was deposed. He was kicked out and replaced by Henry Bolingbroke, who became Henry IV. And in Shakespeare's history plays, Tom, his great cycle goes all the way through to Richard III.
你过奖了。我特别喜欢你在最后几行台词中喉咙哽咽的感觉。嗯，这就是伟大的演员……当你沉思英国陷入内战时。多米尼克，非常非常感人。这并不复杂，汤姆。这只是表演。我知道是这样。所以这就是1399年10月1日理查二世被废黜的那一刻。他被赶下台，由亨利·博林布鲁克取代，后者成为了亨利四世。在莎士比亚的历史剧中，汤姆，他的伟大周期一直延续到理查三世。
Everything starts with that moment. That is the trigger for the Wars of the Roses, for the high drama of the 15th century, for the kind of usurpations and depositions and battles and murders of princes in the tower and all those kinds of things. And it's a great moment. It comes in the midpoint of the Hundred Years' War. So you've done a mighty series on that. And this is often seen as a kind of turning point, certainly in English medieval history. And the question is, was it? Well, that's what we're going to explore today, Dominic, because we have done two episodes on the Great Revolt, the Peasants' Revolt of 1381,
一切都始于那一刻。那是玫瑰战争的导火索，是15世纪高潮迭起的戏剧，是篡位、废黜、战争、塔中王子被谋杀以及所有这类事件的开端。这是一个伟大的时刻。它发生在百年战争的中期。你已经做了一个关于那段历史的宏大系列。这通常被视为一个转折点，至少在英国中世纪史上是这样。问题是，它真的是吗？嗯，这就是我们今天要探讨的，多米尼克，因为我们已经做了两集关于大起义，即1381年农民起义的节目，
but there are more tumultuous episodes in the reign of Richard II. And we've given a massive spoiler alert as to what the most dramatic of all is, the deposition of Richard II. But as you say, the question is, how did Richard II come to be deposed? And how significant is it for the history of the 15th century, which we'll follow through? So Tom, just to recap for those people who are coming to the show after a big break or something, we're at the midpoint of the Hundred Years' War. Edward III, who was Richard II's predecessor, had had this absolutely glorious reign, lots of victors, Cressy, Poitier, and so on. But the English had been effectively forced back. This is now halftime. They're kind of not licking their wounds exactly. Well, they are a bit, I think. Right. Okay. They're in the dressing room and
但理查二世统治时期还有更多动荡的事件。我们已经剧透了其中最戏剧性的一幕，即理查二世的废黜。但正如你所说，问题在于，理查二世是如何被废黜的？这对我们接下来要讲述的15世纪历史有多重要？所以汤姆，为那些在长时间中断后重新收听节目的听众回顾一下，我们正处于百年战争的中期。理查二世的前任爱德华三世曾有过一段绝对辉煌的统治，取得了许多胜利，如克雷西、普瓦捷等等。但英国人实际上已被迫撤退。现在是中场休息。他们并没有完全在舔舐伤口。嗯，我想他们确实有一点。好吧。他们在更衣室里，
they've been hacked around. Right. And people are kind of trying to patch things up. But from the point of view of Richard II, the previous two episodes we did, the problem has been domestic and specifically the Peasants' Revolt, the Great Revolt, as it's called, in 1381. And let's just look at how that might have affected Richard. So he had stood on the Tower of London and he had seen London burning. And I think it's probably not over-psychologising to think that this must have imbued in him a kind of visceral dread of civic disorder. I think he's also only a young boy at this point, he's 14 years old, and it must have given him a feeling of impotence that policy is still basically being decided for him by the people who effectively have the reins of government in their
他们被砍得伤痕累累。没错。人们正试图修补一切。但从理查二世的角度来看，我们之前做的两集节目中，问题在于国内，特别是1381年的农民起义，即所谓的大起义。让我们看看这可能对理查产生了什么影响。他曾站在伦敦塔上，看着伦敦燃烧。我认为，说这在他心中灌输了一种对公民骚乱的本能恐惧，并不算过度心理分析。我想他当时也只是个14岁的少年，这一定让他感到一种无力感，因为政策基本上仍然是由那些实际上掌握着政府大权的人为他决定的，
hands. And yet the paradox is it gives him a massive sense of agency at the same time though, doesn't it? Absolutely, because as we described in the previous episode, Richard is aware that as king he has an incredible charisma, that the people love him. They may hate his ministers, but they love him. And this, of course, is also, I think, part of the swirl of influences that the Peasants' Revolt has on him. So basically the Peasants' Revolt bigs him up in his own mind. It does. And it goes with the grain of the effect of his upbringing. He's not actually the only son of the Black Prince. So there'd been an elder brother, but he died in infancy. The Black Prince, he'd had this glittering court in Bordeaux. He'd then come back to die in Kennington,
掌握在他们手中。然而矛盾的是，这同时也给了他一种巨大的自主感，不是吗？绝对是，正如我们在上一集所描述的，理查意识到作为国王，他拥有令人难以置信的魅力，人民爱戴他。他们可能讨厌他的大臣，但他们爱戴他。当然，我认为这也是农民起义对他产生的影响漩涡的一部分。所以基本上，农民起义在他自己的心中提升了他的地位。确实。这与他成长过程中的影响是一致的。他实际上并不是黑太子的独子。他有一个哥哥，但在婴儿时期就夭折了。黑太子在波尔多拥有辉煌的宫廷。他后来回到肯宁顿去世，
near what today is the Kennington Oval. And Richard, I think, growing up would have absolutely lived with the consciousness of what a tremendous dash his father had displayed as a great lord in his court. And I think that it provides Richard through his childhood up to the Peasants' Revolt and then in the years that follow with a sense that he must uphold his dignity and that it's incredibly important to put on a good show. Because more than their predecessors, Edward III and the Black Prince had been all about spectacle and glamour and chivalry and stuff. Is that right? Absolutely. Yes. And of course, achievement. And there's a slight problem for Richard that he hasn't really achieved
靠近今天的肯宁顿椭圆球场。我想理查在成长过程中，一定完全生活在对他父亲作为伟大领主在宫廷中所展现出的那种非凡气魄的意识中。我认为这为理查从童年到农民起义，以及随后的岁月里提供了一种信念，即他必须维护自己的尊严，而且展现出良好的风度极其重要。因为与他们的前任相比，爱德华三世和黑太子更注重排场、魅力和骑士精神，对吗？绝对是。是的。当然，还有成就。理查有一个小问题，那就是他并没有真正取得
anything. And so I think that that's why perhaps he puts an extra premium on the dignity that he hasn't won it, but he has been given it by God as he sees it. So in Shakespeare's play, there's this famous couplet, not all the waters in the rough rude sea can wash the balm off from an anointed king. And the fact that Richard is anointed and that he has succeeded to the throne by right is incredibly important to him. And in the previous episode, we talked about how Edward the Confessor is Richard's great patron. Richard has been crowned and anointed in Westminster Abbey, the shrine built by Edward the Confessor. And Richard feels that this has set him aside from other mortals, that he, in a sense, is separate from his subjects.
任何成就。所以我认为这就是为什么他可能格外看重尊严，他没有赢得它，但他认为这是上帝赋予他的。在莎士比亚的剧中，有这样一句著名的对联：粗鲁狂暴的大海中的所有海水，都无法洗去受膏国王身上的圣油。理查受过涂油礼，并且通过正当途径继承了王位，这一事实对他来说极其重要。在上一集里，我们谈到了忏悔者爱德华是理查的伟大守护神。理查是在威斯敏斯特教堂加冕并受膏的，那是忏悔者爱德华建造的神殿。理查觉得这使他区别于其他凡人，在某种意义上，他与他的臣民是隔绝的。
And the key detail, I mean, it's kind of announced by the Archbishop of Canterbury shortly after Richard had been crowned, that he's king not by election nor by any such path, but by lawful right of succession. So that's the key. But why does that make him different from previous monarchs of whom the same could be said? It absolutely doesn't. But why does that make him different from previous monarchs of whom the same could be said? It absolutely doesn't. But for Richard, Edward III had demonstrated what a great king he was through military achievement. Richard is a boy, and as he's growing up, therefore he needs to emphasize why he has the right to take over the reins of power. And this right is basically because God wants him to be king. He is the rightful heir to his grandfather. You also have this devotion to kind of display and show, which is also a crucial part of Richard's character. So, I mean, he's not in any way wussy. He's very kind of
关键细节是，坎特伯雷大主教在理查加冕后不久就宣布，他成为国王并非通过选举或任何此类途径，而是通过合法的继承权。这就是关键。但为什么这使他不同于之前的君主，因为同样的话也可以用在他们身上？这绝对没有区别。但为什么这使他不同于之前的君主，因为同样的话也可以用在他们身上？这绝对没有区别。但对理查来说，爱德华三世通过军事成就证明了他是一位伟大的国王。理查还是个孩子，随着他的成长，他需要强调为什么他有权接管权力。这种权利基本上是因为上帝希望他成为国王。他是他祖父合法的继承人。你还有这种对展示和排场的痴迷，这也是理查性格中至关重要的一部分。所以，他绝不是个软弱的人。他非常
strong, loves hunting, in that sense, very much his father's son. But I think he has a slight kind of metrosexual quality. Well, he's often played that way in Shakespeare's playwrights. So the classic one that people may have seen is the TV version with David Tennant. Tennant has kind of very, very long hair and he's very fey and a bit camp. And that's how people normally think of Richard II, right? Well. They get him mixed up with Edward II and they say, oh, he's a bit camp and foppish. I mean, it's not entirely inaccurate.
强壮，热爱狩猎，从这个意义上说，非常像他父亲。但我认为他有一种轻微的都市美男特质。嗯，他在莎士比亚的剧中经常被这样演绎。人们可能看过的经典版本是大卫·田纳特主演的电视版。田纳特留着非常非常长的头发，显得非常阴柔，有点做作。这就是人们通常认为的理查二世，对吧？嗯。他们把他和爱德华二世搞混了，说，哦，他有点做作和浮夸。我的意思是，这并不完全不准确。
So the Monk of Evesham reports that Richard does have kind of long blonde hair, a very pale complexion, and says that his features are feminine. And a lot of the paintings he's given quite kind of feminine features. So that must have been Richard's own commission. So that's not the same as Roman historians saying of emperors, oh, they bleach their hair and they shave their legs with shells or whatever, those kinds of things. This isn't propaganda dissing him. No, quite the contrary. I think it's Richard kind of portraying himself. Essentially, I mean, he's a dedicated follower of fashion. He's very, very stylish. He loves his clothes. I mean, he rather despises the French king,
伊夫舍姆的僧侣记载，理查确实留着长长的金发，肤色非常苍白，并说他的五官很女性化。在许多画作中，他被赋予了相当女性化的特征。所以那一定是理查自己的委托。这与罗马历史学家评价皇帝说他们漂白头发、用贝壳刮腿毛之类的说法不同。这不是贬低他的宣传。不，恰恰相反。我认为这是理查在塑造自己的形象。本质上，他是一个时尚的忠实追随者。他非常非常时髦。他热爱他的衣服。我的意思是，他相当鄙视法国国王，
Charles VI. They go and have a summit in 1396 and the French king wears the same robe three days in succession. And Richard regards this with absolute contempt. So he's kind of endlessly, you know, one day he's wearing a magnificent gown of white velvet and red sleeves and the next an outfit of blue velvet decorated with gold. His table is the best in Europe, most extravagant, lots of spices, lots of kind of ducks inside, turkeys inside, whatever. Turduckens. Turduckens, all that kind of thing. He's also the first English king to use a fork. Oh, that's poor.
查理六世。他们在1396年举行了一次峰会，法国国王连续三天穿着同一件长袍。理查对此表示绝对的蔑视。所以他总是，你知道，今天他穿着一件华丽的白丝绒红袖长袍，明天又换上一套装饰着黄金的蓝色丝绒服装。他的餐桌是欧洲最好的，最奢侈的，有很多香料，有很多鸭子里面塞着火鸡之类的东西。火鸡鸭。火鸡鸭，诸如此类。他也是第一个使用叉子的英国国王。哦，那太糟糕了。
And supposedly to use a handkerchief. I don't approve of either of those innovations. Right. So you as a rugged son of the Shires might regard this with a measure of contempt, but Richard is doing it for political reasons. So it's, you know, again, it's just setting himself aside. It's about making people appreciate that he is someone distinctive. So that's what it's all about. But you can imagine that this must make him a bit of a nightmare to handle as he's growing up. Right. So he's a bit of a diva, basically. Bit of a diva, a bit of a diva, very, very self-conscious very very stylish probably an awkward teenager to have around yeah and i think even more so when um on the 6th of january 1383 he celebrates his 16th birthday
据说还使用了手帕。我不赞成这两种创新。好吧。你作为一个来自郡县的粗犷汉子，可能会对此表示某种程度的蔑视，但理查这样做是有政治原因的。所以，这又是在将自己与众不同。这是为了让人们意识到他是一个独特的人。所以这就是全部意义所在。但你可以想象，随着他的成长，这一定让他变得很难相处。好吧。所以他基本上是个有点作的人。有点作，有点作，非常非常自我意识，非常非常时髦，可能是一个很难相处的尴尬少年，是的，我认为当他在1383年1月6日庆祝16岁生日时，更是如此，
comes of age and he's now the same age as the black prince was when he won his spurs at cressy tom i don't want to say what everybody's thinking but you're rich the second and i'm henry bollingbrook i mean i'm just putting that out there i think that this is a parallel that we may reprise so richard still has lots of uncles on the scene specifically two so john gaunt who we mentioned very very unpopular with the rebels in london who trashed his palace yeah but he remains by miles the richest and most powerful figure in england and he's suspected of aspiring to the throne. This is unfair, actually. He's very, very loyal to his nephew, his much-loved brother's son. And also we have on the scene Thomas of Woodstock,
成年了，他现在的年龄和黑太子在克雷西赢得骑士头衔时一样大。汤姆，我不想说出每个人都在想的事情，但你是理查二世，我是亨利·博林布鲁克。我的意思是，我只是提一下，我认为这是一个我们可能会重演的平行线。所以理查身边仍然有很多叔叔，特别是两个：冈特的约翰，我们提到过，他在伦敦的叛军中非常非常不受欢迎，他们捣毁了他的宫殿，是的，但他仍然是英国最富有、最有权势的人，而且他被怀疑觊觎王位。这其实是不公平的。他对他的侄子，他深爱的兄弟的儿子非常非常忠诚。此外，我们还有伍德斯托克的托马斯，
who had been, you remember in the previous episode, he'd been dashing off to Brittany periodically and not doing very well and then coming back. And he has now been elevated to a dukedom, the Duke of Gloucester. So these are the two guys who feel that basically they should be running the country. The problem is Richard is very much the kind of king who has favorites. So this is something that Edward II, Edward III's father, had been notorious for his favorites. Yeah. And it had ended up kind of bringing him down. Richard, he's got a gang of friends who he favors very, very strongly.
你还记得在上一集里，他曾断断续续地奔赴布列塔尼，表现并不好，然后又回来了。他现在已经被提升为公爵，即格洛斯特公爵。所以这两个人觉得基本上应该是他们来管理国家。问题是理查是一个非常喜欢宠臣的国王。这是爱德华三世的父亲爱德华二世因宠臣而臭名昭著的事情。是的。而且这最终导致了他的垮台。理查有一群他非常非常偏爱的朋友。
So among them, there is a guy called Michael de la Pole, who is from a family of wool merchants from Hull. Glamorous. Very, very, not the kind of person who John of Gaunt necessarily might approve of. But Richard loves him and he sends him off on all kinds of diplomatic missions. And it's Michael de la Pole who finds him a very glamorous bride in the form of Anne of Bohemia, she's called. So she's the daughter of the Holy Roman Emperor.
在他们之中，有一个叫迈克尔·德·拉·波尔的人，他来自赫尔的一个羊毛商人家庭。迷人。非常非常，不是冈特的约翰可能认可的那种人。但理查爱他，并派他执行各种外交任务。正是迈克尔·德·拉·波尔为他找到了一个非常迷人的新娘，名叫波希米亚的安妮。她是神圣罗马帝国皇帝的女儿。
He's brought over. They marry. Very happy marriage, although they don't have children. And as a reward for this, Michael de la Pole is first appointed chancellor. And then in 1385, Richard makes him the Earl of Suffolk. So this is a guy who is on the make. Are they the same age? He's a little bit older. No, he's older. And also older is a guy called Simon Burley. He was
她被带了过来。他们结婚了。婚姻非常幸福，尽管他们没有孩子。作为奖励，迈克尔·德·拉·波尔首先被任命为大法官。然后在1385年，理查封他为萨福克伯爵。所以这是一个正在崛起的人。他们年龄一样吗？他稍微大一点。不，他年纪大。而且年纪也比较大的是一个叫西蒙·伯利的人。他是
Richard's tutor, a very good friend of the Black Prince, had been involved again in the marriage negotiations and is seen by everyone as being incredibly common. So all the nobles regard him as beyond vulgar. So Michael de la la pole and simon burley are older but there is one guy in particular who is richard's age whom he adores his best friend who is a guy called robert de vere the earl of oxford and robert de vere i mean that's a very very epicene favorite kind of name right and there are people who suggest that richard and de vere are lovers i mean they may have been, we don't know, but actually De Vere is a massive womanizer. So there's a big scandal where he runs off with his wife's lady-in-waiting, which is- That's not good.
理查的导师，黑太子的好朋友，也参与了婚姻谈判，被所有人视为极其平庸。所以所有的贵族都认为他极其粗俗。所以迈克尔·德·拉·波尔和西蒙·伯利年纪较大，但有一个人特别值得一提，他与理查同龄，理查非常崇拜他，他最好的朋友，一个叫罗伯特·德·维尔的人，牛津伯爵。罗伯特·德·维尔，我的意思是那是一个非常非常阴柔的宠臣名字，对吧？有人暗示理查和德·维尔是情人，我的意思是他们可能确实是，我们不知道，但实际上德·维尔是一个花花公子。所以有一个巨大的丑闻，他带着他妻子的侍女私奔了，这——那可不好。
Yeah. Very, very poor behavior. And Richard lavishes him with all kinds of titles. So he's the first guy to be made a Marquess in English history. He's made the Marquess of Dublin. Marquess of Dublin. And why Marquess? Is this because it's a fancy title and it's a little bit different? A little bit posh, a little bit foreign. And then in 1386, he gets made the Duke of Ireland, which is... The Duke of Ireland? I didn't know such a title existed. Yeah. So that's nice for our Irish listeners. And so you can imagine that this is really,
是的。非常非常糟糕的行为。理查给了他各种各样的头衔。所以他是英国历史上第一个被封为侯爵的人。他被封为都柏林侯爵。都柏林侯爵。为什么是侯爵？这是因为这是一个时髦的头衔，有点不同吗？有点时髦，有点异国情调。然后在1386年，他被封为爱尔兰公爵，这是……爱尔兰公爵？我不知道还有这样的头衔。是的。所以这对我们的爱尔兰听众来说很好。所以你可以想象这真的，
really pissing off all the great magnates. So the royal uncles, but also leading noblemen. So you've got the Earl of Warwick, you've got the Earl of Arundel, their cross about this. And this obviously matters because Richard II, as king, he can go on about his anointing and how he's appointed by God and all this kind of stuff, but he cannot rule without the backing of the magnates. And I think he's, you know, Edward III, he had been a lad and the Magnets are basically lads and it had been brilliant. So you compared me to Richard II. I mean, it's a bit like when we were on our tour of Australia, you and Theo and Dom chatting about the Champions League quarterfinals in whatever, 2007. And I'm sitting there. So basically, Richard II is not hanging out with
真的激怒了所有的大贵族。所以王室叔叔们，还有主要的贵族。所以你有沃里克伯爵，你有阿伦德尔伯爵，他们对此感到愤怒。这显然很重要，因为理查二世作为国王，他可以喋喋不休地谈论他的涂油礼以及他是如何被上帝任命的等等，但他没有大贵族的支持就无法统治。我认为他，你知道，爱德华三世，他曾经是个小伙子，而大贵族们基本上也是小伙子，这很棒。所以你把我比作理查二世。我的意思是，这有点像我们在澳大利亚巡演时，你和西奥还有多姆在聊2007年欧冠四分之一决赛的时候。而我坐在那里。所以基本上，理查二世并没有和
the magnates talking about the Champions League. He's sitting there with his fork and his handkerchief. Thinking about Christianity, talking about the history of Christianity, all that kind of stuff. And so this means that tensions are created and tensions are further created by the fact that the Hundred Years' War, which is still rumbling on, it isn't going well. Richard II isn't a very good war leader. The French are massing a huge army on the Channel. Richard goes off to try and defeat the Scots. That doesn't go well either. And the result is that basically, the number of people whom Richard can rely on is shrinking and shrinking and shrinking the whole time. And this crisis is then accelerated by two developments in 1386.
大贵族们谈论欧冠。他坐在那里，拿着他的叉子和手帕。思考着基督教，谈论着基督教的历史，诸如此类的事情。所以这意味着紧张局势产生了，而百年战争仍在持续，进展并不顺利，这进一步加剧了紧张局势。理查二世不是一个很好的战争领袖。法国人在海峡集结了一支庞大的军队。理查去试图击败苏格兰人。那也不顺利。结果基本上是，理查可以依靠的人数一直在不断减少。而这场危机在1386年的两个发展中进一步加速了。
Just before you get onto those two developments, Tom, a quick question for you, an obvious question. Everything you were describing about Richard II is kind of medieval politics 101. Yeah. You know, manage your magnates, be nice to the big power brokers, all that stuff. And he has an example in his own family of Edward II. Yeah, he does. Just two kings earlier, who'd made a terrible horlicks of this and ended up supposedly having an encounter with the red hot poker, although that probably
汤姆，在你进入那两个发展阶段之前，先问你一个简单的问题，一个显而易见的问题。你刚才描述的关于理查二世的一切，简直就是中世纪政治入门课。是的。你知道，管理好你的权贵，对那些大权在握的人好一点，诸如此类。而且他在自己的家族中就有爱德华二世这个例子。是的，确实有。就在两代国王之前，他把这些事情搞得一团糟，据说最后还遭遇了红热拨火棍的酷刑，尽管这可能并没有发生。
didn't happen. Why on earth does he not learn the lesson from that? I mean, it's not that long ago. Because I think he doesn't know how else to rule. He's trying to rule as best he can. And the fact that he starts to make some of the same mistakes that his great grandfather had made is kind of irrelevant to him. He's not looking back to make some of the same mistakes that his great-grandfather had made is kind of irrelevant to him. He's not looking back to the example of Edward II. He's trying to do the best that he can. And the fact that he is replaying some of these mistakes, it just points to certain structural deficiencies, I think, in royal government in the 14th century.
他为什么就不能从中吸取教训呢？我的意思是，那件事发生的时间并不久。因为我认为他不知道还能怎么统治。他正在尽他所能去统治。事实上，他开始犯下他曾祖父犯过的一些同样的错误，对他来说似乎无关紧要。他并没有回顾爱德华二世的例子。他只是在尽力而为。而他正在重演这些错误的事实，我认为这恰恰指出了14世纪王室政府在结构上的一些缺陷。
So it's a structural issue as much as it is a temperamental one, do you think? I think it's a structural issue if you are not a successful war leader and if you lack the kind of easy charm that Edward III had had. Yeah. Okay. I think being a lad is a kind of requirement for being a successful medieval king. And that's why, basically, in 1386, two things happen that really accentuate the crisis. The first is that John of Gaunt leaves England, turned out to be for three years. He's gone off to Spain to try and make himself the King of Castile.
所以你认为这既是结构性问题，也是性格问题？我认为如果你不是一个成功的战争领袖，如果你缺乏爱德华三世那种随和的魅力，这就是一个结构性问题。是的。好吧。我认为做一个“小伙子”是成为一名成功的中世纪国王的必要条件。这就是为什么基本上在1386年，发生了两件真正加剧危机的事情。第一件事是冈特的约翰离开了英国，结果一走就是三年。他去了西班牙，试图让自己成为卡斯蒂利亚国王。
So this is a kind of, as you do. And this is a problem for Richard because John of Gaunt, he's the greatest man in the kingdom and had been very supportive of his nephew. And now he's gone, there is a kind of void at the center there is also an absolutely massive invasion scare so you have 30 000 men massed on the french coast a contemporary chronicler compares it to the greek army which had destroyed troy which is you know not the kind of detail that you want yeah you know this is up there with the spanish armada and napoleon in 1805 as one of the great invasion scares i mean we don't remember it because in the event it doesn't happen, but at the time it causes massive panic. And so
所以这就像是，你懂的。这对理查来说是个问题，因为冈特的约翰是王国里最伟大的人，而且一直非常支持他的侄子。现在他走了，中心出现了一种真空。此外，还有一场极其巨大的入侵恐慌，法国海岸集结了3万大军。一位当时的编年史家将其比作摧毁特洛伊的希腊军队，你知道，这可不是你想要的细节。是的，你知道，这和西班牙无敌舰队以及1805年的拿破仑一样，是历史上最严重的入侵恐慌之一。我的意思是，我们不记得它是因为最终它没有发生，但在当时，它引起了巨大的恐慌。所以
Michael de la Pole, who is chancellor, he's the guy who's charged with raising the money that would enable England to see this threat off. And so he summons parliament. Parliament is furious because parliament is getting fed up with being summoned and asked for money. And the MPs demand that Richard sacks de la Pole. And Richard has a hissy fit about this and famously says that he would not dismiss so much as a kitchen scullion from office at the request of mere commoners. Wow. Okay. And this is when Gloucester and the Earl of Arundel, they go to Richard and they specifically remind him of the fate of Edward II. They say, listen, you are skirting with danger here.
担任大法官的迈克尔·德拉波尔，他负责筹集资金，使英国能够抵御这种威胁。于是他召集了议会。议会非常愤怒，因为议会已经厌倦了被召集并被要求提供资金。议员们要求理查解雇德拉波尔。理查对此大发雷霆，并说了一句名言：他绝不会应区区平民的要求而解雇哪怕一个厨房杂役。哇。好吧。就在这时，格洛斯特公爵和阿伦德尔伯爵找到理查，明确提醒他爱德华二世的命运。他们说，听着，你在这里是在玩火。
And Richard is sufficiently alarmed at this that he agrees to dismiss de la Pole. So it's a victory for parliament and it's a victory for the Duke of Gloucester. For the big magnates, the big landowners, yeah. And further humiliations are heaped on Richard. So de la Pole is impeached. So he's charged by Parliament on charges of negligence and of embezzlement. But everyone knows that it's really Richard himself who is being attacked. And Parliament sets up a council that has powers to kind of go through all the royal accounts to check that money hasn't been
理查对此感到非常惊恐，以至于他同意解雇德拉波尔。所以这对议会来说是一场胜利，对格洛斯特公爵来说也是一场胜利。对于那些大权贵、大土地所有者来说，是的。更多的羞辱被强加在理查身上。德拉波尔被弹劾了。他被议会指控玩忽职守和贪污。但每个人都知道，真正受到攻击的是理查本人。议会成立了一个委员会，有权审查所有的皇家账目，以核实资金是否被
embezzled. And this kind of parliamentary commission by November 1386 is basically in charge of the entire government. And it's an incredible humiliation. So that's almost like political land grab by parliament, by the commons and the lords working together, Tom, I guess. Yes. And so this is very popular. And so this parliament is called the wonderful parliament. We've talked about how parliaments in Richard's reign have brilliant names, but Richard obviously doesn't regard it as wonderful at all. I mean, he thinks it's awful. And 1387, he's trying to think, how can I claw the situation back? The problem for him is that he doesn't have access to the levers of government anymore.
贪污了。到1386年11月，这种议会委员会基本上掌控了整个政府。这真是一种令人难以置信的羞辱。所以这几乎就像是议会、下议院和上议院共同进行的政治权力掠夺，汤姆，我想是这样。是的。这非常受欢迎。所以这次议会被称为“奇妙议会”。我们谈过理查统治时期的议会名字有多么精彩，但理查显然一点也不觉得它奇妙。我的意思是，他觉得这太糟糕了。1387年，他试图思考，我该如何扭转局面？对他来说，问题在于他无法再掌控政府的权力杠杆了。
And also the Earl of Arundel, who's one of the magnates who's kind of moved against him, in March 1387, he wins a spectacular victory at sea over the French, which destroys the invasion threat and basically means that England will be free from invasion threats for decades. So it's a great victory. So it looks as though Richard doesn't really have any levers to pull at all. So what he does instead of remaining in London and fighting his corner there is he goes out into the country and he kind of tries to build power bases out in the shires. And one place where he particularly tries to build a power base is Cheshire.
而且，阿伦德尔伯爵，作为反对他的权贵之一，在1387年3月在海上对法国人取得了辉煌的胜利，这摧毁了入侵威胁，基本上意味着英国在未来几十年内将免受入侵威胁。所以这是一场伟大的胜利。看起来理查似乎根本没有任何杠杆可以利用。所以他没有留在伦敦并在那里争取自己的立场，而是走到乡间，试图在郡县建立权力基础。他特别试图建立权力基础的一个地方是柴郡。
And he also pursues a kind of legal route, which is to summon the leading judges in the country. And he's basically asking them, as king, can I do whatever I like? And they say yes, presumably, do they? And they basically say, yes, you can. You can do what you like. Is that because they are royal appointees and they are therefore loyal to him rather than to parliament? No, I think they're looking at the law. I think the king can basically do what he likes.
他还走了一条法律途径，即召集全国的主要法官。他基本上是在问他们，作为国王，我可以做任何我想做的事吗？他们回答说是，大概是这样吧？他们基本上说，是的，你可以。你可以做你想做的事。这是因为他们是王室任命的，因此他们忠于他而不是议会吗？不，我认为他们是在看法律。我认为国王基本上可以做他想做的事。
Their ruling is that the king can, if he wants, dissolve parliament whenever he wants, and that the lords and the commons do not have the right to put forward motions and articles that can overrule his. And they are stating what is constitutional propriety. And so Richard thinks, okay, brilliant. And so this is then fed back to the great magnates and it's obviously the threat of civil war is brewing. So on the 14th of November, there is a meeting between Richard's councillors and the three leading magnates in the country, which is the Duke of Gloucester, the Earl of Arundel and the Earl of Warren. So this is 1387, Tom?
他们的裁决是，如果国王愿意，他可以随时解散议会，而且上议院和下议院没有权利提出可以推翻国王动议和条款的议案。他们是在陈述什么是宪法上的正当性。所以理查心想，好吧，太棒了。这随后被反馈给大权贵们，显然内战的威胁正在酝酿之中。因此，在11月14日，理查的顾问们与国内三位主要权贵举行了会议，他们是格洛斯特公爵、阿伦德尔伯爵和沃伦伯爵。所以这是1387年，汤姆？
1387. The autumn of 1387. Yeah. And these three magnates, they bring an appeal, which is namely a prosecution, against Richard's favourites. So including de la Pole and also including de Vere, Richard's great friend. And the targeting of the favourites is basically a way of hitting at Richard. You can't hit the king, so you target the favourites. It is. Yeah yeah so they come to be called the lord's appellant the lords who are bringing
1387年。1387年的秋天。是的。这三位权贵提出了一项上诉，也就是对理查的宠臣们进行起诉。其中包括德拉波尔，也包括理查的好友德维尔。针对这些宠臣基本上是打击理查的一种方式。你不能打击国王，所以你就针对他的宠臣。确实是这样。是的，是的，所以他们被称为“上诉贵族”，即那些提出
an appeal a prosecution against the king's favorites and three days later they repeat this appeal before richard himself richard kind of plays for time because he knows that up in cheshire devere is raising an army all right devere the guy who he was accused of sleeping with. Yeah. His great pal. The lad who's been running off with his wife's lady-in-waiting. Yeah. So Richard is waiting for De Vere to come to the rescue. But meanwhile, the three lords appellant have been joined by two further lords appellant. And these are contemporaries, again, of Richard. So one of them is a guy called Thomas Mowbray, who's the Earl of Nottingham, who had been a good friend of richard's but has now switched side and the fifth dominic is richard's cousin henry bollingbroke so named after the castle in which he was born
上诉，即起诉国王宠臣的贵族。三天后，他们在理查本人面前重申了这一上诉。理查在拖延时间，因为他知道在柴郡，德维尔正在集结军队。好吧，德维尔，那个被指控与他同床共枕的家伙。是的。他的好哥们。那个和理查妻子的侍女私奔的家伙。是的。所以理查在等待德维尔来救援。但与此同时，三位上诉贵族又加入了两位上诉贵族。这些人也是理查的同时代人。其中一个是托马斯·莫布雷，诺丁汉伯爵，他曾经是理查的好朋友，但现在倒戈了。第五位是理查的堂兄亨利·博林布鲁克，以他出生的城堡命名。
yeah he also becomes one so there are now five lords appellant his own cousin tom his own cousin and henry bollingbroke is the son of john of Gaunt. Yeah. The most powerful man in the world or whatever he's regarded as. Yeah. But he's off in Spain. So I think if John of Gaunt had been in England, he would absolutely have stamped his foot down. But Henry Bolingbroke has kind of agency. And so he can see the way the wind is blowing. And so he joins the other Lord's appellant. And Henry Bolingbroke is at the head of the army that marches from London into Oxfordshire to meet de Vere's army, which is marching down from Cheshire. And they meet at a place called Radcot Bridge, and de Vere is trounced. And he flees abroad, and the Lord's appellant are absolutely triumphant. And Richard is now completely screwed.
是的，他也成为了其中之一，所以现在有五位上诉贵族。他自己的堂兄，汤姆，他自己的堂兄。亨利·博林布鲁克是冈特的约翰的儿子。是的。世界上最有权势的人，或者无论他被认为是什么。是的。但他人在西班牙。所以我想如果冈特的约翰当时在英国，他绝对会坚决制止。但亨利·博林布鲁克有某种主动权。所以他能看出风向。于是他加入了其他上诉贵族的行列。亨利·博林布鲁克率领军队从伦敦进军牛津郡，去迎战从柴郡南下的德维尔的军队。他们在拉德科特桥相遇，德维尔被击溃了。他逃往国外，上诉贵族们大获全胜。理查现在彻底完蛋了。
So he retreats to the tower, as he had done in 1381 in the Great Revolt. And Richard is now completely screwed. So he retreats to the tower as he had done in 1381 in the Great Revolt. And basically he's forced into total surrender. And all kinds of rumors circulate that the Duke of Gloucester had wanted to make himself king. And that for two days, actually, this had been seriously proposed. So Nigel Saul, who's written the definitive biography of Richard II, he says subsequently, I mean, everyone has a kind of a stake in denying that this had happened. But he said in the circumstances, there can be little doubt that for a period of some two or three days, Richard ceased to rule. Okay, Tom, I know we've got to go to a break in a second. But just before
所以他退到了伦敦塔，就像他在1381年大起义时所做的那样。理查现在彻底完蛋了。所以他退到了伦敦塔，就像他在1381年大起义时所做的那样。基本上他被迫彻底投降。各种谣言流传，说格洛斯特公爵曾想让自己成为国王。而且实际上，这件事曾被认真提议过两天。所以奈杰尔·索尔，写了理查二世权威传记的那位，他后来表示，我的意思是，每个人都有某种利害关系去否认这件事曾经发生过。但他表示，在这种情况下，毫无疑问，在两三天的时间里，理查停止了统治。好吧，汤姆，我知道我们马上要休息一下。但在我们休息之前
we do that, if this was happening in Constantinople or something, Richard would have been blinded and sent off to a monastery and he absolutely would have been deposed. Somebody would have replaced him. Why doesn't somebody replace him at this point? He's made a horlicks of things. It's impossible to work with. Sure, he's an anointed king, but we've heard that a million times and people do get deposed. No, no, it really matters. It really matters. People really seriously believe it. I mean, it's not just Richard who's hyping it up. It is profoundly believed. It's a sacrament. So to go against God's anointed is to go against God. But people do sometimes get deposed though. It's very, very difficult to do. Very, very difficult, as we will see.
如果这发生在君士坦丁堡之类的地方，理查早就被弄瞎双眼并被送进修道院了，而且他绝对会被废黜。肯定有人会取代他。为什么此时没有人取代他？他把事情搞得一团糟。根本无法与他共事。当然，他是受膏的国王，但我们已经听过一百万次了，人们确实会被废黜。不，不，这真的很重要。这真的很重要。人们真的非常相信这一点。我的意思是，不仅仅是理查在炒作它。这是被深信不疑的。这是一种圣礼。所以反对上帝的受膏者就是反对上帝。但人们有时确实会被废黜。这非常非常难做到。非常难，正如我们将要看到的。
Okay. And so this is why Richard is not deposed. But of course, they can attack his favourites. So in February 1388, a new parliament is summoned, and this is called the Merciless Parliament. Great name. And that's because they show no mercy to Richard's favourites. So de Vere and de la Pole, who have both escaped to France, they are sentenced to death in their absence. Others of Richard's favourites who have not fled are captured and put to death. And among them is Richard's tutor, Sir Simon Burley. Oh, yeah.
好吧。这就是为什么理查没有被废黜。但当然，他们可以攻击他的宠臣。所以1388年2月，召开了新的议会，这被称为“无情议会”。好名字。这是因为他们对理查的宠臣毫不留情。所以德维尔和德拉波尔，他们都逃到了法国，在缺席的情况下被判处死刑。理查的其他没有逃跑的宠臣被抓获并处死。其中就有理查的导师西蒙·伯利爵士。哦，是的。
The friend of the Black Prince, the guy who everyone had laughed at for being common. And Richard is so upset about this that he goes to his uncle, the Duke of Gloucester, with his queen, and the pair of them fall on their knees and beg for Simon Burley to be spared. And Gloucester refuses point blank. No, he's got to go. He's got to go. And so, you know, it looks as if it's all over for Richard, basically. I mean, he may still be king in name, but his authority seems completely shot to pieces. Yeah.
黑太子的朋友，那个因为出身平民而被所有人嘲笑的家伙。理查对此感到非常难过，以至于他带着王后跪在他的叔叔格洛斯特公爵面前，两人跪地恳求饶恕西蒙·伯利。格洛斯特断然拒绝。不，他必须死。他必须死。所以，你知道，看起来理查基本上全完了。我的意思是，他可能名义上还是国王，但他的权威似乎完全破碎了。是的。
He's been totally humiliated, Tom. How can he possibly come back from this? Well, we'll find out, won't we? We'll go to a break right now, but we will leave on this cliffhanger. Can Richard turn this around? Spoiler alert, he can. And then there's another twist. So we'll see you after the break.
他受到了彻底的羞辱，汤姆。他怎么可能从这件事中恢复过来？嗯，我们会发现的，不是吗？我们现在去休息一下，但我们会留下这个悬念。理查能扭转局面吗？剧透预警，他可以。然后还有另一个转折。所以休息后见。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆是娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Things are looking very bleak for Richard II. His tutor has been executed. Richard fell on bended knee, but it availed him naught.
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《其余皆是历史》。理查二世的情况看起来非常黯淡。他的导师被处决了。理查跪地求饶，但毫无用处。
So, Tom. That's exactly right. It did avail him naught. So, take us back into the story. What happens next? Well, basically, Richard, to begin with, has no choice but to suck it up. I mean, for him, it's a shot like the Great Revolt. And as in the Great Revolt, it confirms him in his essential character traits, one of which is the less power he has,
所以，汤姆。完全正确。确实毫无用处。那么，带我们回到故事中。接下来发生了什么？嗯，基本上，理查起初别无选择，只能忍气吞声。我的意思是，对他来说，这就像大起义一样。正如在大起义中一样，这证实了他性格中的基本特征，其中之一就是他拥有的权力越少，
the more he insists on his dignity as an anointed king. And the more he kind of goes for the kind of the metrosexual option. You know, more show, better clothes, more, more ducks in turkeys, all that kind of thing. Yeah. Because he has no power. He has no power. And he's trying too hard, basically. But I think he has also learned a lesson, which is that he has to play the long game. So basically what he does is to just sit back and wait for the Lord's appellant to screw things up. Because I suppose Richard, by this point, he's had a sense of how challenging it is to rule England. Because the essential problem that England is trying to fight a war that it can't really afford, it hasn't gone away. And so this is a challenge that will face the Lord's appellant.
他就越坚持自己作为受膏国王的尊严。而且他越倾向于那种“都市美男”的选择。你知道，更多的排场，更好的衣服，更多的鸭子和火鸡，诸如此类的事情。是的。因为他没有权力。他没有权力。他基本上是在过度努力。但我认为他也学到了一个教训，那就是他必须打持久战。所以他基本上所做的就是坐下来，等待上诉贵族们把事情搞砸。因为我想理查到这个时候，他已经体会到统治英国是多么具有挑战性。因为英国试图打一场它实际上负担不起的战争这一根本问题并没有消失。所以这是一个上诉贵族们将要面临的挑战。
And so it proves. So Arundelel who'd won this great naval victory he leads a chevauchee into france and it's a complete damp squib doesn't work so that's loads of money that's been blown so just on the war we talked about this as half time in the hundred years war but campaigning is still kind of going on yeah it's a bit of a stalemate and it's a bit of a sultry is it there are no big battles no big battles no right but there's a bit of a stalemate and it's a bit desultory, is it? There are no big battles. No big battles, no. Right. But there's a need to keep England in kind of state of arm preparation.
事实证明确实如此。所以，赢得了那场伟大海上胜利的阿伦德尔，他率领一支骑兵队进入法国，结果完全是一场空，什么也没做成，所以那是浪费了大量的金钱。关于战争，我们谈到这是百年战争的中场休息，但军事行动仍在进行。是的，这有点僵局，有点散漫，是吗？没有大的战役，没有大的战役，没有。对。但这是一个僵局，有点散漫，是吗？没有大的战役。没有大的战役，没有。对。但需要让英国保持某种武装准备状态。
And there remains an expectation that great victories should be won in France. Yeah. The three elder lords appellant are from the generation that had won victories in France. And so this is why people are willing to back them on the expectation that they will go and get victories in France. And then they don't. And so that starts to shred their prestige. And what Richard also does rather cleverly is to bribe Mowbray and Bolingbroke, the younger ones, by giving them kind of fancy jobs. So anyone who has played Kingmaker, the board game about the Wars of the Roses, will remember the Warden of the Northern Marches,
而且人们仍然期望在法国取得伟大的胜利。是的。三位年长的上诉贵族来自那一代在法国取得过胜利的人。这就是为什么人们愿意支持他们，期望他们去法国取得胜利。然后他们没有做到。所以这开始削弱他们的声望。理查还相当聪明地贿赂了莫布雷和博林布鲁克，那些年轻的贵族，给他们安排了一些花哨的工作。所以任何玩过《造王者》（关于玫瑰战争的棋盘游戏）的人都会记得“北方边境守卫”这个职位，
which is a tremendous post you can get. So Mowbray gets appointed Warden of the Northern Marches. He goes off to lead English forces against the Scots. Bolingbroke, likewise, is given new posts, new honours. And the result of this is that by spring 1389, the alliance between the elder generation of Lords Appellant and the two younger ones has kind of broken up and Richard feels that he can seize control back. And so on the 3rd of May, he announces publicly that he is, you know, the boy is back in town and he dismisses all his ministers the next day. And actually Dominic, among his ministers, he dismisses is William of Wickham, who we talked about in the public schools episode. The real Harry Potter episodes. The founder of Winchester.
这是一个非常棒的职位。于是莫布雷被任命为北方边境的守卫官。他带兵去对抗苏格兰人。同样，博林布鲁克也获得了新的职位和荣誉。结果就是，到1389年春天，老一代上诉贵族与两位年轻贵族之间的联盟破裂了，理查德觉得他可以夺回控制权。于是，在5月3日，他公开宣布，那个男孩回来了，并于次日解雇了他所有的部长。事实上，多米尼克，在他解雇的部长中，就有我们在公立学校那一集里提到的威廉·威克姆。真正的哈利·波特剧集。温彻斯特公学的创始人。
Richard is now basically in control. He's taken the reins of power back into his hands. He pursues various kinds of policies. In the field of foreign affairs, the French war is grumbling on. Richard really wants to try and end it. He can't because there's the same problem that he is Duke of Aquitaine. As Duke of Aquitaine, does he pay homage to the French King or not? Richard says, no. The French King says, yes. And so they can't square that circle,
理查德现在基本上掌握了控制权。他重新把权力掌握在自己手中。他推行了各种政策。在外交方面，对法战争仍在持续。理查德真的很想结束这场战争。但他做不到，因为他面临着同样的问题，即他是阿基坦公爵。作为阿基坦公爵，他是否应该向法国国王效忠？理查德说不，法国国王说要。所以他们无法解决这个矛盾。
but they do agree a truce. And this is to run for 28 years, signed in Paris in 1396. And so that kind of frees Richard up to concentrate on domestic affairs. And by domestic affairs, Richard includes Ireland. So you remember he appointed his favourite, the Marquess and then the Duke of Ireland. So Ireland is still very much there. And Richard is the first English king since John, and indeed will be the last English king until William III to go to Ireland. He goes there twice. His stated aim in doing so is to establish good government and just rule over our faithful lieges. That's very nice for the Irish to have Richard going over and taking over.
但他们确实达成了一项休战协议。该协议于1396年在巴黎签署，有效期为28年。这让理查德可以腾出手来专注于国内事务。理查德所说的国内事务包括爱尔兰。还记得他任命了他的宠臣为爱尔兰侯爵，后来又封为爱尔兰公爵吗？所以爱尔兰依然存在。理查德是自约翰王以来第一位前往爱尔兰的英国国王，事实上，他也是威廉三世之前最后一位前往爱尔兰的英国国王。他去了两次。他这样做的既定目标是为我们忠诚的臣民建立良好的政府和公正的统治。理查德亲自过去接管，这对爱尔兰人来说真是太好了。
I think a bit like when the English got thrown out of Normandy back in the 12th century and Edward I decided that he was going to rush around conquering Wales and hammering the Scots. I think, again, this is a slight element of displacement activity. Right. This is compensation. Yeah. But if Richard can't throw his weight around in France, then he'll go and do it in Ireland. Yeah. Does it work? Kind of. The presence of a king with a fair number of people, I mean, it does enable Richard to stabilize Ireland from an English point of view. I mean, let's say from the Irish point of view, but yeah. And at the same time, back in England, Richard is massively cranking up this whole, you know, I'm the chosen one of God,
我想这有点像12世纪英国人被赶出诺曼底，爱德华一世决定匆忙去征服威尔士并痛击苏格兰人一样。我认为，这又是一种轻微的替代活动。没错。这是一种补偿。是的。但如果理查德不能在法国耀武扬威，那他就会去爱尔兰。是的。这管用吗？算是吧。国王带着相当多的人在场，确实使理查德能够从英国的角度稳定爱尔兰。我是说，从爱尔兰人的角度来看，但确实如此。与此同时，在英国，理查德正在大肆宣扬“我是上帝选中的人”这一套。
lots more clothes, lots of portraits of him. People may have seen the famous painting of him with his patron saints kind of kneeling before the Virgin and the infant Christ. It's in the National Gallery in London. So that's the Wilton Diptych, Tom. Yes. A very famous painting. I once went to a lecture by Maurice Keane. Great medieval historian about the Wilton Diptych.
更多的衣服，更多的肖像画。人们可能见过那幅著名的画，画中他与他的守护神在圣母和圣婴面前跪拜。它收藏在伦敦的国家美术馆。那是威尔顿双联画，汤姆。是的。一幅非常著名的画。我曾经听过莫里斯·基恩的讲座。伟大的中世纪历史学家，讲的就是威尔顿双联画。
Yes, of course. Very interesting. Great book on chivalry. Yeah, people can look it up. It's a tremendous painting, actually. And it kind of captures that slightly gilded, spectacular, the sort of desperation to be noticed. This sort of guilt obsession that I equate with Richard II, which I also equate actually with men with long hair.
是的，当然。非常有趣。关于骑士精神的伟大著作。是的，人们可以去查一下。这确实是一幅了不起的画。它捕捉到了那种略带镀金的、壮观的、那种渴望被注意的绝望。这种我与理查二世联系在一起的罪恶感执念，我也把它与留长发的男人联系在一起。
But that's by the by. But it's not just show because Richard is also very effectively making sure that he can raise money in the teeth of protests from Parliament. He's absolutely determined to become financially self-sufficient because he's realized you know that this is the royal achilles heel and so he's having endless rows with parliament he's basically ignoring them he's extorting huge loans from kind of the wealthy capitalists in london and essentially you know he's now employing ministers who are overtly browbeating parliamentary opposition. So in 1397, his chancellor, he has an address where he tells the commons that their duty is complete obedience, that the king governs and their role is simply to enable the king
但这只是题外话。但这不仅仅是作秀，因为理查德也非常有效地确保了他在议会的抗议声中依然能够筹集到资金。他绝对决心实现财政自给自足，因为他意识到这是王室的阿喀琉斯之踵，所以他与议会没完没了地争吵，他基本上无视他们，他从伦敦的富商那里勒索巨额贷款，本质上，他现在雇用的部长们都在公开恐吓议会的反对派。所以在1397年，他的大法官发表了一次演讲，告诉下议院他们的职责是完全服从，国王负责统治，而他们的角色仅仅是使国王
to govern. And this is sufficiently intimidating that the commons do vote Richard two huge grants. And Richard is now, you know, I mean, he's got a lot more money than, say, his regime This is sufficiently intimidating that the Commons do vote Richard two huge grants. He's got a lot more money than, say, his regime had had earlier when he was a child. But of course, it comes at cost because he's alienated London, he's alienated Parliament, there's popular discontent as there had been in 1381, the year of the Great Revolt. And even with all this money that he's screwing out richard is still overspending because you know those robes right yeah they don't come cheap and it probably reminds you dominic and
能够统治。这足以起到威慑作用，下议院确实投票给了理查德两笔巨额拨款。理查德现在，我是说，他比他小时候的政权拥有更多的钱。但这当然是有代价的，因为他疏远了伦敦，疏远了议会，就像1381年大起义那年一样，民众中存在不满情绪。即使有他榨取来的所有这些钱，理查德仍然入不敷出，因为你知道那些长袍，它们可不便宜，这可能会让你想起查理一世，多米尼克。
i'm sure we'll remind listeners of charles the first who likewise has a kind of personal rule alienates london alienates parliament is kind of coming up with all kinds of wheezes and schemes to screw money out and it's the same problem. And loves art. And loves art. Yeah. It's a problem with artistic kings. What's fascinating about it is it's a structural problem with the English monarchy, but I suppose
我相信我们会提醒听众查理一世，他同样有一种个人统治，疏远了伦敦，疏远了议会，想出了各种各样的诡计和计划来榨取钱财，这是同样的问题。而且热爱艺术。而且热爱艺术。是的。这是艺术型国王的一个问题。令人着迷的是，这是英国君主制的一个结构性问题，但我认为
with so many European monarchies that lasts for centuries. I mean, that's the extraordinary thing. Well, I think it's heightened for the English one because of what's happened over the reign of Edward III, that parliament has seized control of the right to grant money to the king. And so this has now been institutionalized by all those kind of parliaments with various groovy names. The merciless parliament. Yeah. So Richard is basically the first king to wrestle with a problem that will haunt his successors throughout the 15th, 16th, and of course, into the 17th century. How can a king raise money without having his power eroded by parliament? And of course, by magnates, because the magnates are still very much on the scene.
对于许多持续了几个世纪的欧洲君主制国家来说也是如此。我的意思是，这才是最非凡的事情。嗯，我认为对于英国君主制来说，由于爱德华三世统治时期发生的事情，这个问题更加突出了，议会已经夺取了向国王拨款的权利。所以这现在已经被所有那些有着各种时髦名字的议会制度化了。无情议会。是的。所以理查德基本上是第一个与这个问题作斗争的国王，这个问题将困扰他的继任者整个15、16世纪，当然还有17世纪。国王如何在不被议会削弱权力的情况下筹集资金？当然，还有权贵们，因为权贵们仍然活跃在舞台上。
The Lord's appellant are still, Richard hasn't been able to deal with them. He wants to. Richard is very much the kind of man who, when he gets insulted or humiliated, he wants to have his vengeance. But he kind of holds his hand because he's learned to play the long game. Also, John of Gaunt has come back from his abortive venture to make himself King of Spain. This is good news for Richard because Gaunt is a very loyal servant of him. It stabilizes the regime. But I think it means that Richard doesn't rush into dealing with the Lord's appellant. But by 1397, he decides that he is ready to make his move. And on the 10th of July in that year, very abruptly, completely without warning, taking everyone by surprise, he orders the arrest of Gloucester, of Arundel, and Warwick.
上诉贵族仍然存在，理查德还没能对付他们。他想这样做。理查德是一个当他受到侮辱或羞辱时，想要报复的人。但他克制住了，因为他学会了放长线钓大鱼。此外，冈特的约翰从他试图让自己成为西班牙国王的失败冒险中回来了。这对理查德来说是个好消息，因为冈特是他非常忠诚的仆人。这稳定了政权。但我认为这意味着理查德并没有急于处理上诉贵族。但到了1397年，他决定准备采取行动了。那年的7月10日，非常突然，完全没有任何预兆，让所有人措手不及，他下令逮捕格洛斯特、阿伦德尔和沃里克。
So the three leading more elderly magnates. So not Bolingbroke and not Mowbray. And on the 15th of July, he goes to parliament and he tells the commons that these three great lords have been arrested, and I quote, for the great number of extortions, oppressions and grievances committed against the king and people and for other offenses against the king's majesty. And that, of course, is turning on its head the charges that the lord's appellant had brought against his favourites. So very, very sweet vengeance. And they're very rapidly dispatched. So Arundel is executed. His brother, who is the Archbishop
也就是三位主要的年长权贵。所以不是博林布鲁克，也不是莫布雷。7月15日，他来到议会，告诉下议院这三位大贵族已经被逮捕，我引用一下，“因为对国王和人民犯下的无数勒索、压迫和冤屈，以及其他违背国王尊严的罪行。”这当然是把上诉贵族对他宠臣提出的指控反转了过来。所以是非常非常甜蜜的复仇。他们很快就被处置了。阿伦德尔被处决了。他的兄弟，也就是坎特伯雷大主教
of Canterbury, is sent off into exile. Warwick is brought before the court and, to everyone's contempt, breaks down. And it's said he sobbed and whined like a wretched old woman oh no so he's sentenced to life imprisonment and gloucester dies in very mysterious circumstances so he is arrested he's sent to calais and there it is reported that he's died you know he died of a cold or something although his valet later reports that he'd been suffocated beneath the mattress beneath a mattress that requires multiple people to hold the mattress down, surely. It's complicated. Right. So, you know, you talked about how this is setting up kind of echoes that will reverberate throughout the 15th century. Of course, he's not the first
被流放了。沃里克被带到法庭，在众人的蔑视下崩溃了。据说他像个可怜的老太婆一样啜泣和哀鸣，哦不，所以他被判终身监禁，而格洛斯特死于非常神秘的情况，所以他被逮捕，被送到加来，据报道他死在那里，你知道，他死于感冒之类的，尽管他的贴身男仆后来报告说他被闷死在床垫下，在床垫下，这肯定需要好几个人按住床垫。这很复杂。对。所以，你知道，你谈到了这如何为整个15世纪产生回响奠定了基础。当然，他不是第一个
member of a royal family to be suffocated by bed linen. So the princes in the tower will suffer a similar fate. Oh, right. You think they were suffocated beneath bed linen? Beneath pillows, wasn't it, supposedly? Yeah, that's the claim. Philip Langley would not be happy with you, Tom. But I think that Gloucester is basically got rid of because Richard doesn't want the embarrassment of his own uncle being brought to trial. So he takes all their lands. This is great. He distributes them among his followers. He also uses the money to raise basically a private army. So lots of archers, lots of men at arms.
被床上用品闷死的王室成员。所以塔里的王子们也会遭遇同样的命运。哦，对。你认为他们是被闷死在床上用品下的吗？据说是枕头下，不是吗？是的，那是说法。菲利普·兰利不会对你感到高兴的，汤姆。但我认为格洛斯特基本上是被除掉了，因为理查德不想让自己的叔叔被审判而感到尴尬。所以他没收了他们所有的土地。这太棒了。他把这些土地分给了他的追随者。他还用这些钱建立了一支私人军队。所以有很多弓箭手，很多武装人员。
And this is something new. No king has ever done this before. You can imagine that watching this, Mowbray and Bolingbroke are very nervous. So they're the two younger men, the two younger men. But they had sort of become reconciled to the king. He had bought them off with offices and titles and things. So why should they be so nervous if they're back on his side? Because they know that he's a very vengeful man. Yeah. And having seen what he's done to the three other lords appellant, they are nervous that the
这是前所未有的。你可以想象，看着这一切，莫布雷和博林布鲁克非常紧张。他们是两个年轻人，两个年轻人。但他们已经与国王和解了。他用官职、头衔之类的东西收买了他们。那么如果他们站在他这一边，为什么还要这么紧张呢？因为他们知道他是一个非常记仇的人。是的。看到他对其他三位上诉贵族所做的一切，他们很紧张，因为
axe is hovering. And so both of them start accusing the other of plotting against the king. And isn't this, Tom, a key thing, the vengefulness? I mean, we haven't massively brought that out in Richard's character. I mean, you can't massively brought that out in Richard's character. I mean, you can be showy and flamboyant and you can be a bit prickly and proud and all those kinds of things, but it's not the key to him that he is so spiteful. He's a vengeful man who will not forgive and forget and compromise. And that's what's going to be his undoing. Right.
斧头悬在头顶。于是他们两人开始互相指责对方密谋反对国王。汤姆，这难道不是关键吗，那种记仇？我的意思是，我们并没有在理查德的性格中过多地表现出这一点。我的意思是，你不能在理查德的性格中过多地表现出这一点。我的意思是，你可以表现得炫耀和浮夸，你可以有点带刺和骄傲，所有这些，但这不是他的关键，他是一个如此刻薄的人。他是一个不会原谅、不会忘记、不会妥协的记仇的人。而这正是他失败的原因。对。
And Mowbray is a childhood friend of his and Bolingbroke is his cousin. So they know him very, very well on a personal level. And so this is why each one accuses the other of plotting against Richard to try and get in Richard's good books. It's a quarrel that over the winter of 1397 to 1398 comes out into the open. It goes to court. It proves impossible for Parliament to decide between them. And so it's decreed that they should settle it by fighting each other. Trial by combat. Massive excitement. Trial by combat. Oh, that's very Hollywood.
莫布雷是他儿时的朋友，博林布鲁克是他的堂兄。所以他们在个人层面上非常非常了解他。这就是为什么每个人都指责对方密谋反对理查德，试图进入理查德的好感名单。这是一场在1397年到1398年冬天公开化的争吵。它闹到了法庭。议会发现很难在他们之间做出决定。于是下令他们通过互相决斗来解决。司法决斗。巨大的兴奋。司法决斗。哦，那太好莱坞了。
And so this is the big sporting event of the year. Everyone is looking forward to it. They're counting down the months. They're counting down the weeks. They're counting down the days. The great day arrives. Mowbray and Bolingbroke come, they get on their armor, they're ready to fight. And then Richard says, stop, you're not going to fight. And this is the moment at which Shakespeare's play Richard II begins. So we are now into Shakespeare's matter of England with our narrative. And he orders Mowbray and Bolingbroke to retire to their respective pavilions. A couple of hours pass, and then Richard announces his judgment that Mowbray is exiled for life and Bolingbroke is exiled for 10 years. So both of them have no choice but to leave. Huge disappointment across England that they've been denied this great spectacle. Disappointment, not relief? No. Everyone had been looking forward to a-
所以这是年度体育盛事。每个人都在期待它。他们在倒计时月份。他们在倒计时周。他们在倒计时天。大日子到了。莫布雷和博林布鲁克来了，他们穿上盔甲，准备战斗。然后理查德说，停下，你们不能打。这就是莎士比亚的戏剧《理查二世》开始的时刻。所以我们现在进入了莎士比亚的英国叙事。他命令莫布雷和博林布鲁克退回到各自的帐篷里。几个小时过去了，然后理查德宣布了他的判决，莫布雷被终身流放，博林布鲁克被流放10年。所以他们两人别无选择，只能离开。整个英国都非常失望，因为他们被剥夺了这场伟大的奇观。失望，而不是如释重负？不。每个人都在期待一场——
Clash of the Titans. Clash of the Titans, exactly exactly and then in the new year so we're now into 1399 john of gaunt dies and he had just allowed his son to be exiled he's very old by this point okay and not really in a position to oppose richard which is why richard had moved when he did against you know all the lord's appellant yeah so with the death of john of gaunt there is now an awkward question because should bolingbroke who who is John of Gaunt's son and heir, and therefore Duke of Lancaster, should he be allowed to come back to England to claim his lands? Which are presumably enormous, right? I mean, John of Gaunt is the great magnate. Yeah. And Richard says, no. He says, you're exiled for life. And this means
泰坦之战。泰坦之战，没错没错，然后在新年，也就是1399年，冈特的约翰去世了，他刚刚允许他的儿子被流放，他当时已经很老了，好吧，并没有真正处于反对理查德的位置，这就是为什么理查德在那个时候对所有上诉贵族采取行动的原因，是的，所以随着冈特的约翰的去世，现在出现了一个尴尬的问题，因为博林布鲁克，也就是冈特的约翰的儿子和继承人，因此是兰开斯特公爵，他是否应该被允许回到英国索回他的土地？这些土地想必非常巨大，对吧？我的意思是，冈特的约翰是伟大的权贵。是的。理查德说，不。他说，你被终身流放了。这意味着
effectively that Richard is clearly eyeing up the lands of the Dukedom of Lancaster and everything that pertains to that, which would give him a kind of overweening financial security and degree of authority over the rest of the kingdom. So he's effectively kind of verging on an absolute monarchy by this point. And if that works for Richard, he's done. That's going to leave him completely sorted out for the rest of his reign and indeed for his successes as well. Yes. So it's a key moment in the history of the monarchy because it would have provided scope for a much more
实际上，理查德显然在觊觎兰开斯特公爵领地的土地以及与之相关的一切，这将给他一种压倒性的财政保障和对王国其余部分的权威程度。所以到目前为止，他实际上已经接近绝对君主制了。如果这对理查德有效，他就成功了。这将使他在余下的统治期间，甚至对他的继任者来说，都完全解决了问题。是的。所以这是君主制历史上的一个关键时刻，因为它本可以提供比理查德所能行使的更
iron-fisted kingship than Richard had been able to exercise. Now, the risk for Richard, of course, is that is Bolingbroke going to take this lying down or the Duke of Lancaster, as we should now call him. And just can you tell us, Tom, about what Bolingbroke is like? Because Bolingbroke is Richard's age-ish, isn't he? Richard is about 30 at this point. He's a hard man and he's ambitious. And as it turns out, he is not willing to allow this kind of humiliation and permanent term of exile to stand. Late June 1399, he gets together a very, very small squadron of ships. He's got a force of men at arms, various Lancastrian banner men who've come to join him in France. He's got the exiled Arundel, the former Archbishop of Canterbury.
铁腕的统治。现在，理查德面临的风险当然是，博林布鲁克会忍气吞声吗，或者我们现在应该称他为兰开斯特公爵。汤姆，你能告诉我们博林布鲁克是什么样的人吗？因为博林布鲁克和理查德年纪差不多，不是吗？理查德此时大约30岁。他是一个强硬的人，很有野心。事实证明，他不愿让这种羞辱和永久流放的条款存在。1399年6月下旬，他召集了一支非常非常小的船队。他有一支武装人员，各种在法国加入他的兰开斯特旗手。他有被流放的阿伦德尔，前坎特伯雷大主教。
They sail into the North Sea and they land at Ravenspur on the Humber Estuary. And the reason that they land there is because this is where Bolingbroke's lands are. And so he is saying at this point, I've only come back to claim my duchy. And with that understanding, the leading magnate in the North, who is a guy called Henry Percy, who has been made the first Earl of Northumberland. And the Percys, of course, will become a massive, massive force in Northern politics. The Percys agree not to oppose him. Do they believe him? They really believe him that he's just after his own? Well, unclear. And this is something that will be a topic of much debate in Henry IV's reign. Meanwhile, Richard is in Ireland on the second of his two trips there. This is a problem because he can't get enough shipping to get all his troops back.
他们驶入北海，在亨伯河口的雷文斯普尔登陆。他们在那里登陆的原因是这是博林布鲁克的土地所在。所以他此时说，我回来只是为了索回我的公国。有了这种理解，北方的领头权贵，一个叫亨利·珀西的人，他被封为第一代诺森伯兰伯爵。当然，珀西家族将成为北方政治中一股巨大巨大的力量。珀西家族同意不反对他。他们相信他吗？他们真的相信他只是为了他自己的土地吗？嗯，不清楚。这是亨利四世统治时期将成为激烈辩论的话题。与此同时，理查德正在进行他两次爱尔兰之行中的第二次。这是一个问题，因为他无法获得足够的船只把所有的军队运回来。
He's stuck there and the delay is fatal because support for him hemorrhages away. Large numbers of magnates who are fed up with Richard's personal rule and the threat of tyranny that they identify with him start to swing behind Bolingbroke. And by the end of July, Henry has effectively secured control of pretty much the whole of England. And on the 29th of July, this is symbolized by the fact that three of Richard's most hated councillors are brought into Market Square in Oxford and publicly executed. And everyone cheers and goes hurrah and tosses their caps in the air and says, hooray for Bolingbroke.
他被困在那里，这种延误是致命的，因为对他的支持流失了。大量厌倦了理查德个人统治以及他们所认定的暴政威胁的权贵开始转向支持博林布鲁克。到7月底，亨利实际上已经确保了对几乎整个英国的控制。7月29日，这一点得到了象征，理查德最痛恨的三名议员被带到牛津的市场广场并公开处决。每个人都欢呼，高喊万岁，把帽子扔向空中，说，博林布鲁克万岁。
Which suggests there's a lot of latent opposition to Richard, presumably because of high taxes. High taxes and because of the sense that he's establishing a tyranny. So people don't like that. Meanwhile, Richard has finally managed to rustle up enough ships. He's landed in Wales, which is not a good place really to try and strike at London from. And he has no support. And so by August, he's recognizing, ah, it's all over. So he meets in Conway Castle with Henry Percy, the Earl of Northumberland, who by now has absolutely swung behind Bolingbroke. And he negotiates his surrender. And on the 19th of August, Richard has moved to Flint Castle, just along the coast in Wales, where he surrenders to Henry Bolingbroke, his cousin.
这表明对理查德存在很多潜在的反对，大概是因为高税收。高税收，以及因为他正在建立暴政的感觉。所以人们不喜欢那样。与此同时，理查德终于设法凑齐了足够的船只。他在威尔士登陆，那并不是一个真正适合从那里打击伦敦的地方。而且他没有任何支持。所以到了8月，他意识到，啊，一切都结束了。所以他在康威城堡会见了诺森伯兰伯爵亨利·珀西，他此时已经完全转向支持博林布鲁克。他谈判投降。8月19日，理查德被转移到威尔士海岸边的弗林特城堡，在那里他向他的堂兄亨利·博林布鲁克投降。
And Henry speaks to Richard and he says, My lord, I have come sooner than you sent for me, and I shall tell you why. It is said that you have governed your people too harshly and that they are discontented. If it is pleasing to the Lord, I shall help you to govern them better. And Richard replies to Henry, if it pleases you, fair cousin, then it pleases us well. Oh, those words must have stuck in his craw. He is saying that through gritted teeth, absolutely gritted teeth. And of course,
亨利对理查德说，我的主，我来得比你传唤我时要早，我会告诉你原因。据说你治理人民太严苛，他们很不满。如果上帝乐意，我将帮助你更好地治理他们。理查德回答亨利，如果这让你高兴，好堂兄，那我们也高兴。哦，那些话一定卡在他的喉咙里了。他是咬牙切齿地说出来的，绝对是咬牙切齿。当然，
he knows that Richard is lying. He knows that his cousin is bitter and vengeful and too dangerous, basically, to allow to live. So Henry's in so deep. But the interesting thing is that this is always presented or often presented as Henry being ambitious, being conn Richard III, that the deadly nature of medieval politics of, dare I say, the Game of Thrones, means that if Henry didn't strike now against Richard, he might as well just slit his wrists. He's doomed, right? Yeah, because that's the lesson of the Lord's Appellant. If you're going to strike at Richard, you've got to finish him off, because otherwise he'll be back at you. You don't want to be Ned Stark, right?
他知道理查德在撒谎。他知道他的堂兄既痛苦又记仇，而且太危险了，基本上不能让他活着。所以亨利陷得太深了。但有趣的是，这总是被表现为，或者经常被表现为亨利有野心，是理查三世，中世纪政治的致命本质，我敢说，权力的游戏，意味着如果亨利现在不对理查德采取行动，他不如直接割腕自杀。他注定要失败，对吧？是的，因为那是上诉贵族的教训。如果你要打击理查德，你必须彻底解决他，否则他会回来找你。你不想成为奈德·史塔克，对吧？
Right. So I think that this is, it's basically, it's self-defense rather than ambition that prompts Henry to aspire to the crown. But of course, the reason why Richard is still latently very, very powerful is that he is an anointed king. No one can dispute that. He rules by right. And so this is a huge problem for Henry.
对。所以我认为这是自卫，而不是野心促使亨利渴望王位。但当然，理查德仍然潜在地非常非常强大的原因是，他是一位受膏的国王。没有人能反驳这一点。他依法统治。所以这对亨利来说是一个巨大的问题。
How is he going to claim the throne? So on the 1st of September, the pair of them finally reached London. Richard is sent to the tower. So the tower again and again is kind of punctuation point in his life. He'd been there during the Peasants' Revolt. He'd been taken there by the Lord's Appellant at the great moment of crisis. And now he's back there And he's a prisoner. Henry summons Parliament. And on the 10th of September, he stops using Richard's regnal year to date his proclamations. And so this is essentially saying Richard is going to be deposed. But how do you justify it? Because the problem is, it's not just getting rid of Richard. It's the fact that Richard's next heir isn't Henry Bolingbroke. It's a guy called Edmund, who's the Earl of March,
他将如何宣称王位？9月1日，两人终于到达伦敦。理查德被送往塔楼。所以塔楼一次又一次地成为他生命中的标点符号。他在农民起义期间就在那里。他在重大危机时刻被上诉贵族带到那里。现在他又回到了那里，他是一个囚犯。亨利召集了议会。9月10日，他停止使用理查德的在位年份来标注他的公告。所以这本质上是在说理查德将被废黜。但你如何证明这一点？因为问题是，不仅仅是除掉理查德。问题在于理查德的下一位继承人不是亨利·博林布鲁克。而是一个叫埃德蒙的人，他是马奇伯爵，
who is descended from Edward III's third son, Lionel, so ahead of John of Gaunt, but via the female line. People who listened to our episode on the Hundred Years' War, the very first one, may remember that this is how the French stopped Edward III succeeding to the French throne. They say that the French crown can't pass down the female line. And so this is basically what Henry does now. It's very, very ironic that the English, having gone to war on the basis that Edward III was a legitimate heir to the French throne by right of female descent, now they're saying, actually, it's illegitimate. And so this is how Henry is able to claim the throne. But obviously it's very, very legally dubious. And Richard
他是爱德华三世第三子莱昂内尔的后裔，所以排在冈特的约翰之前，但通过女性血统。听过我们关于百年战争那一集的人，第一集，可能记得这就是法国人阻止爱德华三世继承法国王位的方式。他们说法国王冠不能通过女性血统传下去。所以这基本上就是亨利现在所做的。非常非常讽刺的是，英国人以爱德华三世是合法的法国王位继承人为由发动战争，现在他们却说，实际上，这是非法的。所以这就是亨利能够宣称王位的方式。但显然这在法律上是非常非常可疑的。理查德
knows this. And so he keeps insisting, I'm the rightful king. I mean, he is the rightful king. But finally, on the 29th of September, he's visited by Henry and Richard recognizes that he has no choice. He takes the crown off his head, puts it on the ground, and he resigns his right to God. That's madness though, Tom. The moment you take the crown off and say, that's it, I'm done, you're dead. Well, he's effectively nothing. He goes back to being Richard of Bordeaux. He was a fool to do that because it was obvious at that point he'd have to be killed.
知道这一点。所以他一直坚持，我是合法的国王。我的意思是，他确实是合法的国王。但最终，在9月29日，亨利拜访了他，理查德意识到他别无选择。他摘下头上的王冠，放在地上，他向上帝辞去了他的权利。那太疯狂了，汤姆。你摘下王冠说，就这样，我完了的那一刻，你就死定了。嗯，他实际上什么都不是。他变回了波尔多的理查德。他那样做是个傻瓜，因为那时很明显他必须被杀。
Do you not think? I mean, who knows what menaces Richard faced? He probably knows he's going to be killed anyway. So the 30th of September, Parliament approves Richard's deposition. And on the 13th of October, which is the feast day of Edward the Confessor, so Richard's great patron, Henry is crowned in Westminster Abbey. And there's all kinds of attempts to burnish this coronation. People who listen to our coronation episodes may remember Henry IV is the first to wear what's called the Imperial Crown, a crown where metal struts go over the head. There's also a special oil that is supposed to have been given by the Virgin to Thomas Becket.
你不觉得吗？我的意思是，谁知道理查德面临什么威胁？他可能知道无论如何他都会被杀。所以9月30日，议会批准了理查德的废黜。10月13日，也就是忏悔者爱德华的节日，理查德伟大的守护神，亨利在威斯敏斯特教堂加冕。人们试图美化这次加冕礼。听过我们加冕礼剧集的人可能记得亨利四世是第一个佩戴所谓的帝国皇冠的人，一种金属支柱越过头顶的皇冠。还有一种特殊的油，据说是圣母赐给托马斯·贝克特的。
That definitely happened. Basically, they're pulling out all stops. It's a real problem. Henry is plainly an illegitimate king, and so there are people who can never accept him as king. Henry is aware of this, is aware that Richard basically can't be allowed to hang around on the scene. First of all, he's sent to the castle of Leeds in Kent, and then he's sent to the great Lancastrian stronghold of Pontefract in the north, which is absolutely secure.
那肯定发生了。基本上，他们竭尽全力。这是一个真正的问题。亨利显然是一个非法的国王，所以有些人永远无法接受他为国王。亨利意识到了这一点，意识到理查德基本上不能被允许留在现场。首先，他被送到肯特郡的利兹城堡，然后他被送到北方的兰开斯特大本营庞特弗拉特，那里绝对安全。
In January 1400, there is a Ricardian uprising. It's not very good. It's crushed. And Henry now knows he has no choice. And so the following month, Richard is killed. So there are two versions of this in Shakespeare's play. He's hacked to death by a group of guards led by a guy called Sir Piers of Exton. But it seems from contemporary sources, it's likely that he was just starved to death so
1400年1月，发生了一场理查德派起义。不太成功。它被镇压了。亨利现在知道他别无选择。所以次月，理查德被杀。莎士比亚的戏剧中有两个版本。他被一群由皮尔斯·埃克斯顿爵士领导的卫兵乱刀砍死。但从当代资料来看，他很可能只是被饿死的，
that no one would have responsibility for killing an anointed king. And a remarkable thing to me, looking at this story, is how closely it anticipates the position in 1483. I mean, this is the story of the princess and the tower. Yeah. You know, it's one of the reasons I think it's pretty obvious, to me anyway, that they were killed by Richard III. Yeah. Is that that is an action replay of the same story. The powerful guy, the relative, who's in an impossible position.
这样就没有人需要为杀害一位受膏的国王负责。对我来说，看着这个故事，一件非凡的事情是它与1483年的局势有多么相似。我的意思是，这就是塔里王子的故事。是的。你知道，我认为这很明显，至少对我来说，他们是被理查三世杀害的原因之一。是的。那是同一个故事的重演。那个强大的家伙，那个亲戚，处于一个不可能的境地。
And basically, if he doesn't take the crown himself, he'll be killed. But then that raises the issue of what you do with the person you've deposed. And basically, you have to get rid of them. Otherwise, there'll be a focus for rebellions. And that's why Shakespeare's great suite of history plays that goes from Richard II to Richard III do form this incredible unity. Although they're written at very different periods in Shakespeare's life, the deposition of Richard II and Richard III's coup d'etat in the Richard III play, they do bookend this extraordinary narrative. Henry Bolingbroke, unlike Richard III, does not try and disguise what has happened. So Richard II's body is brought in state from Pontefract down to London,
基本上，如果他不亲自夺取王冠，他就会被杀。但这引发了你如何处理被你废黜的人的问题。基本上，你必须除掉他们。否则，他们将成为叛乱的焦点。这就是为什么莎士比亚从《理查二世》到《理查三世》的伟大历史剧系列形成了这种不可思议的统一性。尽管它们是在莎士比亚生命中非常不同的时期写的，但《理查二世》的废黜和《理查三世》剧中的政变，确实为这个非凡的叙事画上了句号。亨利·博林布鲁克与理查三世不同，他并不试图掩盖所发生的事情。所以理查二世的遗体从庞特弗拉特被隆重地运往伦敦，
stops along the way. Henry wants everyone to know that Richard is dead so that there won't be kind of pretenders popping up left, right, and center. And there's a requiem mass held in Westminster. And then the body is sent off to a Dominican friary in Hertfordshire. And because Richard, he was a great patron of architecture, as you could imagine, with his metrosexual tastes, he built himself an absolutely sumptuous tomb, but he doesn't end up buried in it. And all kinds of moralists marvel on this, you know, fortune ordered it otherwise, all this kind of thing. Although to be fair to Henry V, who I've often dissed, he does put Richard in the tomb that he prepared in Westminster Abbey. That's typical of Henry V. What a great man.
沿途停靠。亨利希望每个人都知道理查德已经死了，这样就不会有冒充者到处冒出来。威斯敏斯特举行了安魂弥撒。然后遗体被送往赫特福德郡的一座多米尼加修道院。因为理查德，他是一位伟大的建筑赞助人，正如你所能想象的那样，有着他那种都市男性的品味，他为自己建造了一座绝对豪华的坟墓，但他最终并没有被埋葬在里面。各种道德家对此感到惊奇，你知道，命运另有安排，诸如此类。尽管对亨利五世公平地说，我经常贬低他，但他确实把理查德安葬在他准备的威斯敏斯特教堂的坟墓里。这很典型亨利五世。多伟大的人啊。
Yeah. So, I mean, Richard is clearly a massive failure. I mean, there's no other way of judging him but as a failure. But I do think that he's fascinating because the problems that he faces and the solutions that he attempts do look forward to the problems that face kings throughout the 15th century and the Tudors and the Stuarts. And I think that, I mean, Shakespeare is not wrong that the deposition does kind of generate a crisis of authority, certainly for the Lancastrian monarchy. Yeah. It does undermine the legitimacy of Henry IV, of his son, Henry V, and of his son, Henry VI. And that will, in the long term, lead to the instability that will result in the Wars of
是的。所以，我的意思是，理查德显然是一个巨大的失败。我的意思是，除了失败之外，没有其他评价他的方式。但我确实认为他很迷人，因为他面临的问题和他尝试的解决方案确实展望了整个15世纪以及都铎王朝和斯图亚特王朝国王面临的问题。我认为，我的意思是，莎士比亚说废黜确实产生了一种权威危机，这并没有错，至少对于兰开斯特君主制来说是这样。是的。它确实削弱了亨利四世、他的儿子亨利五世和他的儿子亨利六世的合法性。从长远来看，这将导致导致玫瑰战争的不稳定性。
the Roses. Yeah. So I think that it's not a completely mad position, the one articulated. From that point onwards, Tom, am I right in thinking there's a cloud in the English sky and that cloud is the storm cloud of civil war? The storm cloud of civil war. I think you're right. That is beautifully and poetically put, but I don't think that we can end this episode
是的。所以我认为，这并不是一个完全疯狂的立场，那个被阐述的立场。从那时起，汤姆，我是否可以认为英国的天空有一朵云，那朵云就是内战的风暴云？内战的风暴云。我想你是对的。这表达得既优美又富有诗意，但我认为我们不能结束这一集
with your poetry. What? When we have Shakespeare's poetry to hand, Dominic. Really? Oh, that's shocking. Would you like me to read it? Would you enjoy that? I would love you to read because this is Richard II contemplating his deposition, and it's one of the great passages in the whole of Shakespeare. And it's one of the great pieces of commentary on kingship, full stop. And fortunately, we have a great performer to do it justice to. We do. But Dominic, just before you give us some Shakespeare, just to mention there will be more
用你的诗歌。什么？当我们手头有莎士比亚的诗歌时，多米尼克。真的吗？哦，那太令人震惊了。你想让我读吗？你会喜欢吗？我很乐意让你读，因为这是理查二世在思考他的废黜，这是莎士比亚全集中最伟大的段落之一。这是关于君主制的伟大评论之一，句号。幸运的是，我们有一位伟大的表演者来公正地对待它。我们有。但多米尼克，在你给我们读一些莎士比亚之前，只是提一下，会有更多
poetry in our next episode, which will be on Chaucer and the Canterbury Tales, which was written in Richard II's reign and will be the final part of our four-part swing through the rule of Richard II. And if you want that immediately, you can of course access it by joining the Restless History Club. Otherwise, this will be going out on Thursday. Now, Dominic, Shakespeare, take it away. Okay, here we go.
诗歌在我们的下一集中，那一集将关于乔叟和《坎特伯雷故事集》，它是在理查二世统治时期写的，将是我们四部分理查二世统治之旅的最后一部分。如果你想立即获得它，你当然可以通过加入“其余历史俱乐部”来访问它。否则，这一集将于周四播出。现在，多米尼克，莎士比亚，开始吧。好的，我们开始。
For God's sake, let us sit upon the ground and tell sad stories of the death of kings. How some have been deposed, some slain in war, some haunted by the ghosts they have deposed, some slain in war, some haunted by the ghosts they have deposed, some poisoned by their wives, some sleeping killed, all murdered. For within the hollow crown that rounds the mortal temples of a king keeps death his court. And there the antic sits, scoffing his state and grinning at his pomp, allowing him a breath, a little scene to monarchize, be feared, and kill with looks, infusing him with self and vain conceit, as if this flesh, which walls about our life, were brass impregnable, and humored thus, comes at the last, and with a little pin bores through his castle
看在上帝的份上，让我们坐在地上，讲讲国王死亡的悲伤故事。有些人被废黜了，有些人死于战争，有些人被他们废黜的鬼魂所困扰，有些人被他们的妻子毒死，有些人睡梦中被杀，全部被谋杀。因为在环绕国王凡人太阳穴的空心王冠内，死亡保持着他的宫廷。在那里，那个滑稽的人坐着，嘲笑他的状态，对着他的排场咧嘴笑，让他喘口气，一个小场景来称王，被恐惧，用眼神杀人，用自我和虚荣的自负灌输他，好像这堵住我们生命的肉体，是坚不可摧的黄铜，就这样被纵容，最后到来，用一根小针钻过他的城堡
wall, and farewell king. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
墙，再见国王。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《其余的是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。